londo they call it the hollow realm and
it has links to a primordial serpent to
New Londo to Velka the goddess of sin
and to the most intriguing hard-to-get
ending of Dark Souls 3 it's a hugely
significant location from a law point of
view and I'm confident that this is
where the DLC will be based let me paint
a picture of long door for you Londo is
a society of undead comprised of corpses
and shades who have led unsavory lives
as such these hollows are deeply
detested and hated which is nothing new
for hollow kind really it's even been
recorded that sometimes a hollow will
use a purging stone to remove the
physical effects of the undead curse
temporarily reversing their hollowing
and occasionally a hollow will even fool
himself into thinking he's no longer
cursed and will turn on his own kind
which reminds me of what Heydrich says
down here this pit is for hollows not
for the likes of you same folk or
perhaps you are a hollow posing as
otherwise and I tell you these things
because even though the hollows of Londo
are hated even though they sometimes
fight amongst themselves they still
remain a truly unique example of hollows
forming a society and that is
interesting because undead are a
powerful force if they have a purpose we
see that in the undead legion who fought
the abyss and we see that in every
protagonist from a Dark Souls game
really so it begs the question what are
the undying hollows of Londo
fighting for and what are they bound by
the age of fire was founded
by the old cards sustained by the
linking of the fire but the gods are no
more and the all-powerful fire deserves
a new heir our Lord of Hallows it shall
be who whereas the true face of mankind
this is yuria seeker of the Lord of
Hallows and one of the three maidens who
founded the sable Church of Londo the
sable Church translates to the black
church and its towers are said to
resemble the eight jagged branches of
the mauryan blade the church is said to
offer salvation to hollows which must be
a pretty attractive tagline for cursed
individuals I'd wager that if I was
cursed with on death then I'd be pretty
open to a little bit of faith to keep me
from hollowing so it's very clearly
implied that the sable Church is what
keeps the hollows of LAN door grounded
this faith is not an oath taken lightly
however because those who [ __ ] up are
exiled and they're given the words to
the atonement miracle hollows who recite
this miracle think that they're reciting
words of forgiveness but in reality the
atonement miracle makes you attract more
attention from foes and increases enemy
aggro range that's a pretty evil
punishment not only are you exiled
you're exiled and you have death
following you everywhere the three
maidens who founded disable Church they
cut an imposing figure all three are
highly skilled fencers so skilled in
fact that they were able to found
disabled Church between just the three
of them
the third eldest daughter is named
Lillian a woman who seems to have
contributed a lot of the theology behind
the church she was the first to speak
the words of the lond or Braille divine
tome and is also said to recount tales
that portray the suffering and conflict
of Hallows Lillian is not featured in
game not yet anyway
the second eldest is you
and if Lillian was the speaker then urea
would be the swordswoman
as she is said to have claimed a hundred
lives with her weapon dark drift this
legendary cursed sword with an unseen
blade that penetrates straight through
shields nothing can defend from dark
drift and the eldest the firstborn
daughter she's not been named but we
know that she exists because these three
daughters founded the church and the
only others in this equation that go
without names will they're the mother
and the father of the three daughters
and surely these parents are important
right because why else would there be
three founders that are referenced as
daughters with mentions to their order
of birth so the only reason I can think
of that they would do this is that the
parents are important and I think I know
who the mother might be but that
speculation will wait till the end of
the video at any rate these three
daughters are described as maidens of a
primordial serpent and when we murder
yuria we figure out who this servant is
greetings undead warrior I am the
primordial serpent dark stalker cough I
can guide thee and illuminate the truth
your ancestor claimed the Dark Soul and
waited for fire to subside and soon the
flames did fade and only dark remained
thus began the age of men the age of
dark
however Lord Gwyn trembled at the dark
clinging to his age of fire and in dire
fear of humans and the Dark Lord who
would one day be born amongst them Lord
Gwyn resisted the course of nature by
sacrificing himself to link the fire
and commanding his children to Shepherd
the humans Gwyn has blurred your past to
prevent the birth of the Dark Lord I am
the primordial serpent I seek to right
the wrongs of the past to discover our
true Lord the primordial serpent of dark
souls one who corrupted the four kings
who polluted the kingdom of Allah seal
with the abyss is back and now through
urea through the sable Church of LAN
door the pilgrims yeol Qarth
continues to seek a ruler of men they
failed me every last one of them they
were strong but saw not the truth I am
certain that you will prove different
cuff and disable Church are watching
events in lothric very closely because
the world is on the precipice of the
linking of the fire and disable Church
are determined to influence that event
hundreds of long door pilgrims are sent
towards the highest towers of lothric
castle so many of them have died on the
way here and there presumably coming
here because the lothric bloodline is
obsessed with creating a worthy heir to
link the fire and that's the event that
Londo
want to influence however they're kind
of out of luck because lothric refused
to link the fire and you the uncontested
fate met with y'all a pilgrim who had
all but given up ah you have attained
ample strength all will soon be clear my
good
thanks to the young soul is redeemed
allow me to express my gratitude in his
stead when we meet with yuria she
frequently mentions how she's keeping an
eye on all of those who could
potentially be a lord of hollows or Beck
is one Henry
another but she believes that you are
the true Lord of hollows and compels you
to strike down or Beck before he becomes
a threat and to claim an Riis dark
sigils in this ritual within the dark
mode - if you betray urea and you don't
do a quest in time or you straight up
attack her then the pale shade blonde or
will hunt you down but if you're allied
with urea then the pale shade will
assist you throughout the world another
thing to note is that many characters
associated with LAN door use bleed
weapons like dark drift or the Mauryan
blade or the manikin claws and blood
loss is also a proven way to slow the
reanimation of the undying so that would
be a pretty popular weapon in a land
full of hollows it's amazing the level
of depth in this game when you look into
it so let's talk about the undying about
the undead curse the dark sigils and the
dark sign I've noticed a trend when
characters talk about the dark sign they
often call it a shackle something
weighing mendel with dark unshackled a
curse will be upon us and cast off the
shackles placed upon your brethren one
who might shatter the shackles of fate
how am i fooled whose they are rob
unaware is ground and you from the
undead curse is often referenced as
appearing after Gwyn linked the fire so
we assumed that Gwen is at fault somehow
it's the gods who shackled us and while
we don't quite know how it started we do
know what happens to Undead cursed with
the dark sign for when the undead dies
it is never truly dead but only one step
closer to Halloween
not all undead or hollows but all
hollows were once undead you might be
wondering what are dark sigils well I'm
assuming that they're synonymous with
the dark sign and the description of the
dark sigils says that they're a problem
because our humanity literally leaks out
of them and the gap that that creates is
filled with the accumulation of the
undead curse so our character is always
in the process of losing his dark soul
becoming more like the hollows that all
humanoid beings appear to have stemmed
from and for ages Undead have been
shepherded towards the first flame to
fuel it to link it to sit at it and
reset the world and keep the gods in
their age of fire but the world was
never meant to be stuck in this age of
fire it was supposed to go the age of
ancients the age of fire and then the
age of man natural progression but this
age this age of fire it struggles to die
much in the same way that the undead
struggled to die I mean you even see the
dark sign in the sky towards the end of
the game that's pretty symbolic it is
all a curse and it is your cursed flesh
that will inherit the flame undead are
literally burned as fuel for the
bonfires that perpetuate this age and I
had a realization I finally understand
that this is what we see in the opening
cutscene we see the soul of cinder
burning and undead to ash assumedly to
be buried in the untended graves which
remember are not far at all from the
kiln and then we arise from this undead
ash as unconditional in Miyazaki's words
unhindered our undead who failed to link
the fire and were burnt to ash they
exist to inherit the past and put an end
to this cumulative tale so the
unconditioned err we're not just the
corpse of an undead we're Bo
we're something new a new species for
lack of a better word that has a choice
the undead curse no longer has the power
over us that it once had
we can choose to fuel the bonfires and
burn like charcoal or we could choose to
embrace the undead curse itself let's go
back to Dark Souls 2 where it actually
foreshadows a lot of this happening
vendrick a past Lord of Light and a Lord
of mankind who lost himself to the curse
I think he knew that this was the way it
would end or at least he thought it
would with fire they say a true king can
harness the curse a lie but I knew no
better inherit fire and harness the dark
such is the calling of a true leader
we are the unconverted fire
we are the cursed undead who harnesses
the dark we gain levels through the
power of the dark sigil and we even kill
other powerful hollows and claim their
sigils for our own so that we can be
strong enough to claim the first flame
for mankind and that is a new ending Oh
Lord amnesia dine heart is fixed upon
the linking of the fire but brave
usurper i prithee when the moment cometh
to link the fire rested from its mantle
so that we hollows in most honest shape
of man may have it for her own you want
to know what confused me most in Dark
Souls 2 I probably avoided talking about
it because it didn't make sense and I
couldn't make an episode on something
that didn't really make much sense so
the prepared to cry episode 4 nashandra
is missing because i could not figure
out her motives at the time but now I
think I get it so she was the fragment
of the abyss that usurped the age of
fire from her Lord of Light vendrick and
after this drangleic faded into dark so
you think great she won she got exactly
what she wanted right
the world has plummeted into dark so
surely she'd want to keep it that way
right wrong because she calls us her run
dead she guides us she tells us where to
find vendrick she tells us where to find
the Giants she guides this bearer of the
curse all the way to the first flame and
we kill her that doesn't seem very smart
but she says
and now I think I understand
I think nashandra needs an undead I
think she needed to Wed vendrick to
claim the first flame but he ran away to
the Crypt where she couldn't follow him
so she needed a replacement the bearer
of the curse I think that's why she led
us here if you proceed nashandra will
come after you knowing that you will
take the throne and link the fire she
covets the first flame and the great
soul in a similar manner I think we Wed
honoree in this bizarre murder ritual
and can subsequently claim the first
flame like nashandra wanted to I always
found it strange that a being of dark
would want to claim the first flame I
just thought they would want to stop
people thinking it and let it die but in
Dark Souls 3 we learned that you can
usurp it and we learned that those of
londo are making a real push for that to
happen so dark souls2 aside in the Lord
of Hallows ending of Dark Souls 3 we
stifle the first flame within our bodies
and collapse when we rise reborn you see
this beautiful little detail you see the
Sun in the background is no longer red
like the dark sign its ringed with white
and there's this illusion where we lift
this new Sun into the sky signaling and
symbolizing a new age for mankind
this video is crazy long but the best is
yet to come there's two things I'm very
excited about saying in the next DLC and
I do think it's really likely that we'll
get lond or DLC so one is that there's
this boss in Dark Souls 1 that was
called undead King Jarl and he was cut
from the new londo experience of Dark
Souls 1 and I have a lot of fond
memories of discovering
jereal from another Dark Souls youtuber
Hellkite Drake is really good at digging
in the game's files so since New Londo
mirrors LAN door which I guess is new
New Londo I'm pretty hyped
- maybe fight Joe real in the DLC who
know
but the biggest curiosity and you see a
clue in the thumbnail is Velka the
goddess of sin because I personally
think it's undeniable that Velka is
heavily involved in LAN door and velka
the goddess of sin is one of the most
influential and curiously the most
absent characters of the soul series so
velka the goddess of sin is a rogue
deity but she is versed in arts both new
and old and is considered to have a
great range of influence even as gods
are concerned so let me convince you of
her involvement in LAN door so her
followers wear a uniform black just like
the three founders of the sable Church
and one of them in Dark Souls 1 was
called Oswald who was an inhuman
swordsman a fencer to be exact just like
the three daughters who found a disabled
church and in Dark Souls 1 and 2 these
servants of velka were called the
Pardoner's men who listened to the
confessions of sinners and the keywords
being they offered salvation the sable
church too is also said to offer
salvation so I think if anyone is going
to be the mother to the three daughters
of disable Church then I would put my
money on Velka 100% many spells like vow
of silence
are the spells and rights of Velka in
Dark Souls 1 and in Dark Souls 3 they're
said to originate from Londo in Dark
Souls 1 also with the clutch rings that
were said to reach out to the
crestfallen and prevent despair in
previous games they were said to belong
to a dark deity and here now in Dark
Souls 3 those same rings are fabled in
lond or to prevent the despair of men
speaking of rings we get the sacrifice
rings from Yeol's ashes the hollow ashes
and the sacrifice rings also directly
referenced Velka I'm still going with my
list velka also oversees the Dark Moon
list of the guilty in Dark Souls 1 which
was a covenant led by dark sun gwyndolin
and in Dark Souls 3 this could explain
why we sacrifice unruhe in the dark moon
- she has a relationship with the dark
moons as well so it's crazy the amount
of links there are here but one more
there is a lonely statue of Velka in the
undead settlement and this statue can
dissolve Halloween it can cure hollowing
in the same way that a purging stone
does so Velka is irrefutable linked to
the dark side and disabled Church of
Londo
I think that's pretty undeniable but
most curious is she is a rogue goddess
the other gods feared and hell I
wouldn't be surprised if Velka is the
one that holds the final few secrets of
the Dark Souls series wouldn't it make
sense if Felker was the one punishing
the world for the first sin Food for
Thought time will tell thank you for
watching and I'll see you all soon
you